the one thing about me uh you don't have
to coach my effort
i'm gonna give 110 percent when i step
on the court
are you serious
there you go stockton gets his screens
screened i feel like the reason why i'm
entering draft
now um the time is right what i showed
this past season
talk to my coaching staff my family and
um
you know i'm ready for the next
challenge you know that next step in my
life
the longest drive process ever right you
know i think we all know that
but you know all in all it's been really
good for him i think this is probably
the biggest gap of time when he's really
been able to focus
on himself and his individual skill
we're all anxious we're ready for
november 18th but
um i think it has been good in in that
he's been able to work on himself and
get better
he's had to endure a lot of patience a
lot of flexibility
uh but you know what it's just gonna
make him tougher and that much more of a
pro
at the next level
johnson yes
dodson leans in looking back on this
kansas year
it was special we're number one in the
nation for three straight weeks we won
the conference title that was our goal
coming into the season
oh boy johnson that late game success
i think it's just a natural thing that
i've always had since i was little i
never wanted to lose in anything
it could be a card game uno game i'm
just never trying to lose
we played in the basement a lot and like
sometimes we'll play one-on-one
and um it'll get kind of rough because
you know we're pretty physical we both
hated to lose so
we kind of go back and forth get mad
because one person fouled each other too
hard
i went to um the same school as him
um when he was in middle school and like
he was like the star
you know of the basketball team that's
when he started taking it seriously
because he was really good
at such a young age around sixth grade
my older brother
actually the reason why i got serious
with it
he he's three years older than me and
that's when he started to get serious
with it so i tried to follow in his
footsteps
and uh that's when things started to
pick up started to
see my game advance he grew up watching
derek rose so
that's kind of been the person that he's
watched
at an early age and um you know he
modeled a lot of this game because
you know he had quickness he has some uh
explosiveness
like derek um how derek likes to attack
the basket and attacking transition
and you know those are the two biggest
strengths of devon is just being able to
beat his man out to dribble and the push
tempo in transition
[Music]
it's been an incredible journey he's
always played at a high level
he's always been very competitive um
you know all three all three children
you know sports in general just teaches
a lot of life lessons
my seventh grade year which was his
fourth grade year we played on the same
like travel team you know he was three
grades behind me and like i saw like how
he was
you know competing with us competing
with my peers competing with seventh
graders
at fourth grade so at that time i knew
like oh no he's pretty good in
basketball and i think that
he could take it far
sports in general has always been big in
our family
but basketball has kind of taken the the
main focus
my sister got into it my brother plays
it's just a sport that we all love we
weren't playing one-on-one we would kind
of like visualize us
like in the nba so we would like play
against the invisible team as if we were
an nba team
we would go back to our rooms like uh
get on the plane
do interviews between games and kind of
just like
experience the whole nba it's been a
long wait so it's going to be
a sense of relief almost like oh you
know
we're finally here and just knowing
where your
you know child is going to be and grow
and thrive
what i learned most is control what you
can control
you know there's things that are going
to be above what you can control
and as long as you stay level-headed
stay locked in and continue
to work at it every day stuff should
find its way
you know the amount of work and amount
of dedication that it takes you know
you can't i mean sometimes on the
weekends you want to go hang out you
know you got to stay in the gym
and you know work overtime but you know
i wouldn't trade it for anything
as a big brother seeing my little
brother accomplish all his dreams
it's definitely gonna be a proud feeling
and i'm looking forward to it
you know it's just been gratifying as a
dad just to see
how hard he's worked at it and the
benefits that it's receiving from it
just really grateful for this
opportunity and and we know he's going
to
do big things for him to be able to live
his dream
is not only inspiring but i'm just like
genuinely proud for him because i know
that's what he's always wanted since he
was little
[Music]